a young Nanaimo woman is making
headlines for winning one of the
craziest races in the world despite
knocking herself unconscious during the
competition warning first this video is
a little bit jarring but it does have a
happy ending 19 year old Delaney Irving
was taking part in the women's event at
the annual UK race near Gloucester
chasing a roll of cheese down Cooper's
Hill when this happened
[Applause]
race officials scrambled a shield
Delaney from Spectators and she was
stretchered to the medical tent she did
regain Consciousness and recovered
enough to give an interview
first question how are you I'm good now
that I remember it I'm good you took
hell of a tumble did I yeah so what do
you remember of the race
um I remember running and then I hurt my
head and then I woke up in the tent
makes it feel to be the winner if
it is are you going to come back next
to reclaim your title I think I will if
I yeah if I see around to it yes despite
the injuries despite the injuries I
think it's worth it
so what does she win for that well
that's it just the roll of cheese
apparently uh Delaney's Mother by the
way says she saw the footage of her
daughter's Adventure but thankfully
after she talked to her and she says so
far her daughter is okay
I didn't know she was doing it I thought
she was watching it and apparently she
has a concussion she was getting a CT
scan but I think she's fine as far as I
know she looked like a rag doll and and
when she landed she wasn't moving so
yeah it was you know not every parent's
dream but she's okay she's okay so
that's all that matters I said are you
okay and I said go to the hospital and I
love you and you're crazy and I love you
and that was pretty much what I said